um for you uh this album you have some
West Coast I mean you've always been
super tapped in in La for like I love
Cali you know that not I feel it's like
it's definitely your second home you
know that and you've been embraced by
California heavily from day one you got
tiger and uh young Gerald on the uh See
Red Dog and G-Eazy and you know what's
crazy about this album like I didn't
I've said this to the homies but
everybody delivered bro every feature
it's gonna be better you're Dave East
but they but but still but you know
sometimes they'll just be like all right
people just give you a verse yeah I've
dealt with that like if if it's like you
sending a song like damn now I gotta
come with me you know I'm gonna talk I'm
talking so at the end of the day you
don't want to just get burnt on the
record but at the same time it's almost
like
numbers part like the tiger record and
the G-Eazy record ain't really no
lyrical
right type of joints like we just those
is kind of more fun right you know what
I mean like but they delivered if you
put a big shout out you put tiger on
like a random Alchemist beat I'd be just
gonna talk I'd be disappointed but but
nobody I don't feel like that's what you
want to hear like I don't think when I
heard the beat actually you know what I
do want to hear that me too I want to
hear tiger and Alchemist do five songs
EP challenge to The Alchemist tiger can
rap bro I feel like people don't
understand that he came up under Lil
Wayne I don't know one of the one of the
greatest Wheezy one of the greatest bro
you don't think Italian can rap
I mean he can rap like like rap oh but
you're just so used to hitting him on a
certain type of [__] you know what he
had a song his first album he had a song
on his album
like really can spit and I'm a [__]
people that rap I don't know so his
first album the one had Rack City on it
he did have a song with Big Sean and a
song with Nas and he kept up with them
on both records for sure I'll say that
but but but this is what I learned
is that me oh that's my Android bro
that's true man what's called on my
Android you should jump in man hotline
man that's like my old old number I
learned this in this game bro you got to
go with what what what the people love
him you know what I'm saying a lot of
times and you gotta go with
was feeding your family you got to go
what's what's what's making in life how
you want it to be so if this is winning
that's why I love like I'm gonna do
what's winning 100 I salute them I only
got to do that [__] all day same thing
with like when Flo Rida was like kind of
like came in with po boy and then he
caught a wave and Flo Rida's like I'ma
just do pop records and I'm like bro I
ain't mad at you and look what he look
how he ran it up he just bought Celsius
I know he sued Celsius for like 40
million dollars he ran it big shout out
to Flo Rida he ran it the [__] ran it up
I'm a fan of [__] running the [__] up
like 100 I'm a fan of that uh anybody
knew you like it like that you're a fan
of right now that you're maybe outside
of anyone you're like directly
affiliated with but like anybody who
just noticing what they're doing and you
appreciate it in the music game
um new newer folks yes
ah let me see
um
who's new right now that I feel like
December December is hard Simba's fire
December talk he pulled up shouts The
Melodies my brother Blanco he brought
him out on on the last tour I had shout
out any you know what else I like like
Beyond rap bro like I know a lot of
[__] that can rap with me it'd be
about like who you are as a person when
I meet you or you know I'm saying like a
lot of the most solid a lot of people
pull up and they like a like a like a
superhero or their character yeah bro
take off the rapper yeah they didn't put
it in them like I like people that's
just them bro like no matter how dope
you all what you got going on just be
yourself cause I'm always myself like in
any environment so he's somebody that
really caught my eye I'm in tune with
him
um
I'm trying to think
uh that's new damn
I feel like it's a few that's how that's
hard
but I'm really thinking about who really
like talking like he wanted him that's I
feel like that's talking like as far as
on some miracle [__] you know
um you probably had to shoot some names
out I feel like certain names I'm gonna
say I already worked with it type [__]
somebody who I think you'd like
who shares the same uh love for the
color blue is uh
big X the plug he's from Houston are
he's from Dallas Texas big extra plug he
talking he fired he's like my favorite
rapper he's [__] we got some [__]
with him I'm gonna tap him no I gotta
meet him he's just this big dude who
[__] just be [__] I'm gonna
definitely tapping I'm one of them that
being so much in my own world bro like
it don't be a knock to nobody but I
gotta get put on this [__] like you know
what I'm saying like a lot of [__] I got
put on to through the homies or just
people around me like yo check this out
so you know I mean once I tap in then
I'll be like oh that [__] hard you know
what I'm saying